my name is Christy and I am from Houston
Texas and I have a channel on YouTube
that's called the former mrs. Jones
initially I started an Instagram account
because I really wanted to connect with
other people who do the Dave Ramsey plan
because I just don't know anybody in my
real life that I can connect with and
social media is this great platform
where you can connect with other people
I had my sick and tired of being sick
and tired moment one evening when we
were in our old house and my husband
came home from work and he needed gas
for his truck
there was nothing in our bank account
and our credit cards were maxed out so I
got in his truck I drove to the gas
station and I was just praying that the
gas pump would take my credit card it
was 11:30 at night and I thought if it
doesn't take this credit card I I may
not be able to get home it was in that
moment where I realized I had to do
something different and so a few days
later just by chance I saw where the
Shaytards had uploaded their debt-free
screen video I just thought who is this
Dave Ramsey guy is just so and he wasn't
talking about like the stock market and
all this like scary stuff that I don't
understand he was talking about not
going to the movies not going out to eat
and saving your money and so I googled
Dave Ramsey I found his radio show and
it was just within five minutes I was
totally hooked
that same day after discovering Dave
Ramsey I printed out his baby steps I
brought it home and in my husband's
defense I probably came on a little
strong because I think my eyes were
crossed and there was just steam coming
out of my ears and I was like this
a-frame see guys says that you need to
sell all your stuff you need a man up
and we need to you know become debt-free
and so a year later is whenever he got
on board I don't know I thought it maybe
was a phase you were going through we
went back and forth and he was
definitely the spouse that was not on
board with Dave Ramsey but slowly and
surely he started to kind of crack a
little bit and he started you know
listening to some of the things that I
was saying and as soon as he started
listening to Dave Ramsey is when it
started to click for him one of the big
things that got him on board was that he
wanted to go back to school and school
is obviously very expensive it's
thousands of dollars a semester so we
could not pay that out of pocket because
we just had all this debt this is my
husband Matt and I think you could say
that he's a spender and I'm the I'm the
I'm Miller form spender reformed spender
okay but you were the one that had you
know what about a year took you to get
on board a Dave Ramsey about a year of
poking prodding yeah haha and finally
afterwards and this is kind of a really
funny story because this is the original
printout that I brought home the very
first day that I heard about Dave Ramsey
and which is website and I printed out
everything and a few days later Matt
drew a fun little picture on Dave's face
it just made me realize that like okay
yeah I mean I guess that shows my
reluctance to get on board and eat your
little horns on Dave Ramsey yeah hey
it was insane because I didn't think
that he was serious about it but one day
I look out my window and of our old
house and in the driveway my husband had
this 2010 ninja motorcycle and he was
out there watching it and he started
taking pictures of it and I asked him
what he was doing and he said well I'm
gonna sell it and I was it was just very
surprising to me because I thought no I
mean are you serious are you sure you
know and it kind of scared me a little
bit but he listed it on Craigslist and
some guy came that night with $6,000 in
cash and bought it I'm so excited about
this two days later he had a 2004 SVT
Ford Lightning he put that on Craigslist
and sold that also in three days he sold
both of his vehicles and eliminated
$20,000 with the debts my husband who is
really into cars and motorcycles and all
that stuff didn't have a car so I had to
drive him to work so I knew he was on
board once I got him on board he wishes
the dynamite for the launch am and we
sold everything and was able to
eliminate the rest of the $20,000 of
debt for the nine months I do these
videos and I connect with you all and um
you know y'all y'all keep me accountable
when I first started my channel I did
not think that I would get any followers
and it wasn't really my intention to do
that I just really wanted to talk about
Dave Ramsey and I think I kind of worked
out with my husband so I realized that I
needed to you know maybe sit down and do
YouTube videos and I could talk about
Dave Ramsey because I was real geeked up
about it and the more and more I did
videos the more people would contact me
and say hey you know your video really
inspired me and it's things like that
that's so empowering that you helped
guide somebody to Dave Ramsey because
he's changed my life so much I realized
quickly after starting my youtube
channel but there are these other
channels that were also getting out of
debt and I just started connecting with
them and is ghazal intense live like no
one else
budget girl debt-free and one two three
our life on a budget I mean there are so
many other channels out there who are
either paying off their debt or they are
debt free and I think what's so great
about them is that they help as
motivation because Dave Ramsey talks
about getting out of debt and how you
get out of debt but these channels are
actually showing you what it's like for
people to pay off their debt and
continue to live debt-free a lot of
people you know when after baby step two
in my path they're dead I think people
get really fired up and they're moving
along and they're paying off their debt
and then once they accomplish that you
know even day talks about that it's not
a sprint it's a marathon and I think
what's important is that these channels
help document hey you know not only do
we pay off our debt but this is how we
continue to live debt-free and we're
saving for a car or we're cash flowing
college or you know we're buying a house
or have a 20% down payment I think that
that's what's important is that this is
not just a two-year process whenever you
become debt-free you it's a lifelong
choice that you continue to you know
live debt-free so anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed and thanks so much for watching
guys and I will see y'all in the next
video
Oh